là ce que je vais faire c'est fait pas
tout l'un mais la masse est un peu tôt
pour que je puisse récupérer un kit et
de matière pour ensuite pouvoir l'afutt
les 1500 degrés c'est à cette
température qu'isabelle travaille le
verre quotidiennement en perles ou en
sculpture c'est aussi une matière
qu'elle façonne depuis 30 ans
son admiration est toujours aussi forte
le vert en tant que tel à partir du
moment où je vais travailler au
chalumeau
il a la même il a même le même degré de
passion et c'est pas l'objet final qui
va faire que je vais préférer une pièce
à une autre c'est vraiment le travail
accompli au chalumeau entre mais demain
c'est de toujours avoir ce qu'on dira
cette appétence et 7 contre ses
priorités pour ce verre qu'il faut quand
même de dompter apprivoiser la matière
un geste qui s'acquiert après plus de
dix ans de pratique il a belle a fait
ses débuts dans la verrerie scientifique
un milieu technique mais qui laissait
trop peu de classe à sa créativité c'est
dans les années 90 qu'elle laisse libre
cours à son imagination dans la verrerie
d'art avec cette découverte de ce métier
je me suis dit je vais pouvoir lier un
beau métier avec le travail de mme emma
et ça c'était important pour moi je
pense que ça a été cette curiosité et sa
alliés en même temps
gérer le côté technique le côté manuel
le côté créatif couleurs harmonieuses et
élégance des formes la manipulation du
verre en fusion nécessitent adresse et
patience un art accessible par un c ap
on a l'équivalent du bac à bac + 2
certains souffleur de verre propose même
des stages individuels pour transmettre
leur passion